In this lecture, we have
seen a particular application
of sentiment
analysis on Twitter.
However, the area of sentiment
analysis is much broader.
Over 7,000 research articles
have been written on the topic.
Hundreds of start-ups are
developing sentiment analysis
solutions.
Many websites perform
real-time analysis of tweets.
For example,
"tweetfeel" shows trends
given any term, and
"The Stock Sonar"
shows sentiment
and stock prices.
Let's talk about text
analytics a bit more generally.
Sentiment analysis is a
particular application
of text analytics.
In general, the critical
aspect of text analytics
is to select the
specific features that
are relevant in a
particular application.
In addition, it's important to
apply specific knowledge that
often leads to better results.
For example, using the meaning
of the symbols or include
features like the
number of words.
Let's finally discuss
the analytics edge
that we have seen
in this lecture.
Analytical sentiment
analysis we have seen
can replace more labor-intensive
methods like polling.
Text analytics can also deal
with the massive amounts
of unstructured data being
generated on the internet.
Computers are
becoming more and more
capable of interacting
with humans
and performing human tasks.
In the next lecture,
we'll discuss IBM Watson,
an impressive feat in the
area of text analytics.